In so all of you in the good old us of a
have missed the turkeys running around
for dear life this week.
Tomorrow is Thanksgiving without even a
close second.
Thanksgiving is by far my favorite
holiday of the year.
I find that focusing on the three F's,
family,
friends,
and food usually brings out the best in
just about everybody between the trip to
fan from the Turkey,
your booze of choice and football in the
background.
All of us,
at least in my experience,
are just a little bit better on this
day,
which we've set aside to give thanks for
all the goodness in our lives.
Thanksgiving is the ultimate reminder of
what it means to be American.
While most of us have the usual staples
of Turkey,
mashed potatoes,
stuffing,
and cranberry sauce around the table.
We also bring in traditions from our own
cultures,
ethnicities,
and nationalities.
This blending of flavors,
languages,
and customs from all over the world is
what makes Thanksgiving a uniquely
American holiday.
No offense to Canadian thanksgiving.
The melting pot that we've created here
has given more freedom to more people
for more walks of life than any other
country in the history of the world
today.
People still yearning to come to America
to take part in our freedom and pretty
much nobody wants to leave America.
No matter how often celebrities say that
they will.
This doesn't mean we're perfect or
anywhere close to it,
but it does mean that our tradition of
freedom based on and rooted in the
pursuit of life,
liberty,
and happiness is a pretty good starting
point for how to build a truly liberal
and tolerant society.
While politics will undoubtedly be
discussed around the Thanksgiving table
this year,
I'm going to do my best to try to veer
the conversation always to what brings
us together rather than what rips us
apart.
Maybe your uncle is pro life and you're
a pro choice.
Maybe your sister voted for Hillary,
but you voted for trump.
Maybe you want low taxes and your dad
wants to redistribute wealth.
Whatever those differences are,
they are actually the very reason that
this country is so great.
We all get to have our own opinion and
fight for what we believe,
but beyond just the ability to be
tolerant of people who are different
from us.
It's more important that we can still
learn from live with and even love
people who think differently than we do.
I hope you have a wonderful day
tomorrow,
filled with those three f's I mentioned
earlier,
friends,
family and food,
and maybe one more f if you get lucky.
Either way.
Let's give thanks tomorrow for all the
goodness we have,
but often forget to even acknowledge
happy Thanksgiving to you and all your
loved ones.
Joining me today is the creator of the
Dilbert Comic Strip,
author of the new book win bigly and a
guy who seems to make some pretty spot
on predictions.
Scott Adams,
welcome back to the Rubin report.
Thanks for me.
Before
we begin,
I gotTa Tell Ya,
I was looking at these blurbs on the
back of this book.
How did you get these people,
William Shakespeare,
Mark Twain,
Alexander the Great Abe Lincoln,
and even this Scott Adams guy.
I mean,
how in the world did you pull this off?
I stick with dead people because they
can't complain later.
It's like,
no,
not one of them has complained that I've
misquoted them.
You know Mark Twain,
he said nothing about his quote.
So what?
I saw this,
I thought immediately there must be an
estate for some of these people that
monitor these types of things.
Do you even have to think about that?
Does the editor or the publisher goes,
Scott,
you can't play in.
Come on.
Well,
luckily my job is parody and so,
so I know those laws pretty well.
As long as it's obvious parody,
you can do anything you want.
So we checked right before you walked
in.
We had you on the show September,
first of 2016,
about two months before the election and
when I had you on,
you were one of the only people that I
thought basically was making sense of
what was going on with trump at the
time.
You didn't say you were a trump
supporter.
I think you actually said you were not a
trump supporter.
You had sort of said the thing about you
are in a hostage situation with Hillary,
but you know,
basically you were saying here's what
trump is doing.
I don't necessarily support it.
I think you buy the election time.
You officially did support him,
right?
Yeah.
The because of one issue.
Basically when,
when Clinton came out with the,
uh,
the estate tax plan and I realized that
I personally would pay roughly seventy
five cents on every dollar I would learn
from the rest of my life,
which would basically make me retire.
I wouldn't possibly work for that.
Um,
so that,
that changed my mind.
Yeah.
I wasn't going to jump into the estate
tax,
but I do find it when one of the
interesting things,
I don't stand to make a windfall from
the estate tax,
but I find it one of those things where
it's like,
this money has been taxed for someone's
entire life.
Your money that you earned through all
your hard work has been taxed your whole
life.
Hopefully you've made good investments
and whatever else you've done.
I met at the end.
The government just says,
okay,
we're going to just basically take more
than half of it at that point after
we've already taken it the whole time,
the whole tax thing.
There's no way to make it fair because
there's always somebody who's going to
complain,
but some things just feel less fair and
that feels more like confiscation than
tax.
Yeah.
But I guess it's easy to be one of those
people that just are like,
well,
I'm not involved in this.
I don't stand to win anything of it,
so why wouldn't I want to take the money
from other people?
Right.
Yeah.
That's the big problem with the
democratic system.
People can vote a vote other people's
money into their pocket if there are
enough of them voting.
Yeah.
Alright,
so it's a little over a year ago that we
had you on.
You're making some sense of the,
of the techniques that are,
that you're writing about in this book
about persuasion and what trump is doing
and all that.
Around that time,
just like two months before you actually
did you really think it was real?
I did really believe that he was going
to win those weeks that we're talking
about and most of the time up to them,
they don't.
The only time my confidence was really
shaken was the same time everybody else
was after the access Hollywood pussy,
pussy gay thing dropped.
I don't think anybody thought that day
that he could get out of that.
I haven't heard of one person who said,
yeah,
that that didn't bother me at all,
but it was just amazing.
There was so much news that that whole
cycle and so much more came after that.
That even something that large didn't
have the impact it would have had
because it got lost and you know the.
The,
the enormity of it all.
Yeah.
What does that tell you?
Generally about truth right now.
Now the subtitle of your book is
persuasion.
In a world where facts don't matter,
facts and truth have a little something
to do with each other.
What does that actually tell you that
something like that could happen
regardless of whether you think it was
just something he said or locker room
talk or all that nonsense,
but that things don't stick in a way.
They used to.
Let me,
let me give some context for people who
are new to me in addition to cartooning
and writing and stuff.
Uh,
I'm a trained hypnotist and I've been
studying persuasion in all its forms
for,
for decades.
So I was looking at it through that
filter and one of the things that
hypnotist learned is that people are
irrational pretty much all the time and
they just rationalize their decisions
and believed that it made sense all
along.
And that's the normal way of things.
Until you get into that mindset,
the whole world looks confusing.
You can't understand why you gave you a
good reasons and your facts and your
logic and the person you're talking to
didn't change their mind.
So my view on the election was that are
certainly by the time that the access
Hollywood tape dropped,
probably almost every mind was made up.
They didn't know why,
but they had made up their minds for
emotional,
irrational,
whatever reasons,
so it's tough to dislodge somebody,
you know,
he would have had to murder somebody in
public to change minds at that point,
that late stage because people were
really hardened in their opinions by
then.
Yeah.
What does that tell you?
I mean,
as we're taping this,
this will be up next week,
so a little right before thanksgiving.
We're taping this on the.
Today's the eighth today.
Does that sound right?
Okay.
That sounds good.
You're a pro.
Um,
what does that tell you as I'm watching
all these people on twitter in the last
day or so with this,
thank you,
Hillary Hashtag and all this stuff and
this continued worship of her,
even though by every estimation,
she probably was the worst candidate in
the history of American politics.
That might be a bit of an overblown
statement,
but what does that day that they're
still on this,
there's still on this thing that both
rumble but consider that a statement.
We consider it now a given that she was
one of the worst candidates we've ever
seen prior to the election and really
maybe up right up until election day.
The general thought on both sides was,
this is one of the strongest candidates
we've ever seen for everything from
funding to experience too.
It was time for a,
for a woman.
People were emotionally and every other
way.
The world was for that,
so it's only after the fact that we've
now reinterpreted what we saw as well as
she was the worst candidate ever and I
don't know if either one of those is
true.
I think we had two candidates who had
some real big pluses.
She had lots of pluses and some real big
flaws in both cases.
Yeah.
Do you think that basically trump from
before the election,
so,
so during the process until now,
after a year of governing basically or
10 months or so of governing has
basically used this book.
I know he didn't have it,
but you know what I mean,
like has he,
is this really what he has done from
beat one that you saw before?
So you have to understand his entire
life arc starts with going to a church
where his pastor was Norman Vincent
Peale,
the famous author who wrote the power of
positive thinking,
and so that's,
that's the first place you probably
learned persuasion,
at least one corner of persuasion
because in his time Norman Vincent Peale
was actually accused of being a
hypnotist.
He was that influential.
So that optimism,
you see him using it all the time to
make us think into the future.
When he talks about the GDP,
he doesn't say,
well,
we've got three percent.
That's pretty good.
That's what a normal president would
say.
He says,
we've got three percent,
but without the hurricanes,
I think it would have been for.
We've probably got four percent.
I think we'll do better than that.
He was actually talking us into the
future and if you,
if you consider how an economy works,
unless you have shortages of stuff,
and we're,
we're really,
you know,
in a great time because we don't have
shortages of anything.
It's psychology that drives it.
So if people think we're heading to four
percent,
they're going to invest a little bit
more this year to get ready for that,
and that's what makes it four percent.
He's actually taking what he learned as
a child and you know,
that,
that persuasive thinking into the future
of driving the economy that way.
And then if you look at his full,
full range of he knows how to sell
marketing,
branding,
nobody doubts any of those skills at
this point.
Um,
and then negotiating,
he wrote literally,
you know,
authored with a coauthor,
a book on negotiating.
So he's seen persuasion from every,
every angle including design,
you know,
he's,
he's the one who I believe came up with
or at least approved the hats,
make America great again.
And I think people will look back at
this for 40 years and say that was the
best branding we've ever seen.
Yeah,
it's interesting to me because you said
the positive way he speaks and then you
gave some examples.
But if you listen to the,
just the general narrative out there,
this is the most divisive president at
the time.
He says all these horrible things,
what do you make of that portion of him,
the twitter portion that's fighting with
people still all the time doing things
that in my opinion are below the office
of the presidency and I say that as
someone that that I really did.
The reason I wasn't surprised when trump
won was because I actually sat down with
you right before and I listened and I
started seeing
this stuff,
so I wasn't thoroughly.
I was on Rogan,
Joe Rogan the day before the election,
or maybe it was election day actually,
and I was like,
yeah,
I think it's possible.
And did I actually change your mind on
that?
Well,
I don't know that you can fully changed
my mind,
but you made me aware of what was
happening.
I think basically before I sat down with
you,
I was sort of where I think a lot of
people still are,
which is they're just grabbing for
anything.
You know what I mean?
Like they're just,
they have nothing that they're really
basing any decisions on.
They see the tweets,
they scream about the tweets or they
don't even have a chance to scream about
the tweets because the media gets
outraged before they can even process it
and,
and you sort of framed it in a way that
basically said to me,
there's something sensible about this is
what I think most people have kind of
missed that.
One of the things that is deeply
important for persuasion is first you
have to get people's attention.
That's like phase one at this point can,
can anybody argue that he's the best
we've ever seen at getting attention,
right?
That's that one.
Even his biggest haters and say,
yeah,
I like the way he has dominated the
media and every conversation,
yes,
so step out and get attention and the
way he does that is he.
He operates in what I call a narrow band
of wrongness,
meaning that if this is appropriate
behavior,
he just takes it up to this band with
the nicknames and the provocative things
he says,
but he never does up here where you'd
get impeached.
You'd be putting in the insane asylum
and start a nuclear war.
If you look how long he's been doing
this and how,
uh,
how consistently stays in that narrow
band of wrongness,
which is persuasion perfection because
you can't look away and then you're
thinking about why he wants you to think
about now consider also that he's also
been meeting with a lot of world leaders
at this point.
He doesn't do that in that context,
so it's clear that he can modify his
behavior to get the effect he needs.
We didn't know that for sure.
I'll say other people didn't know that
for sure.
You know,
when he was running it looked a little
crazy and maybe under control,
but now we've seen the fine control he
puts on it,
you know,
on twitter,
that narrow band that wrongness every
time in real life you can modulate
everything being equal as a smart guy
and a bright guy and an author and
someone that cares about words and all
of those things.
Putting trump aside for a moment,
would you prefer that we just had a
president that was a little more within
the common standards of decency or seem
to really appreciate.
You know,
I keep telling this story that I was in
DC a couple weeks ago and I went to all
the monuments.
I was reading all the great things that
Jefferson wrote in George Washington all
like,
it's very different than when they look
back and they put trump's tweet next to
all of it.
Well,
I have mixed feelings for one lot.
One of the things that the people on the
left,
let's say the the anti trumpers,
whoever they are,
don't get is how entertaining he is to
his base.
The people who actually like what he's
got to offer find it amazingly
entertaining and funny.
So the things that people are saying,
oh,
I can't believe you said that.
These using a front to all civilization.
That's why it's funny.
It's funny because we know he does it
intentionally.
We know the effect it'll have on a of
group of people and that's sort of the
joke that it has that effect that as to
your question,
we were never offered somebody who had
his,
his talents and his specific policies
that appealed to a lot of people who
voted for him without the flaws.
You're nobody offered the,
you know,
the trump without the tweets that make
people angry.
And I would argue that probably 80
percent of the things that feel like
they're over the live actually are
functional and the 20 percent then
maybe,
you know,
how do you mean functional gets
attention.
That puts a nickname on somebody that
actually takes them completely out of
the primaries.
We saw that with low energy jeb and I
think the crooked hillary thing was,
was quite effective.
But there are other things that are
maybe just too far,
you know,
a little they don't have.
They're not so far.
He gets impeached but they're not
useful.
Um,
but they also don't seem to hurt him in
the long run.
We've seen something we may never see
again,
which is a complete disconnect between
approval ratings,
which are terrible and people's image of
what the economy is doing.
For example,
business confidence is great.
I don't think we'll ever see those
disconnect again and it's because of his
style.
Does that also show you that people just
don't care about Paul's anymore?
I mean,
I saw Paul on Sunday on CNN and it's
said,
you know,
half of Americans don't trust trump,
and I thought,
well,
half of Americans don't trust CNN.
I mean all of the.
You know what I mean?
It's like you guys through all these
numbers at us before you through all
this nonsense at us before and now
you're still throwing nonsense and I
don't try.
I really almost trust none of it and I.
It makes it harder to,
to siphon some truth out and now the
onus is on a.
I was just saying a pole that was saying
that something about,
boy,
people think the leaders think of the
president and I'm thinking,
how do we know what leaders of other
countries think of the president?
What,
what good is that?
Apple,
right.
So yeah,
we're a little while.
Is that even relevant in,
in an odd way,
you know,
so if they fear us,
certain countries,
we want them to fear so they probably
won't like the president,
whether it's trump or obama or anyone
else.
Well,
I've been saying from the beginning,
one of the big things that scared people
about,
uh,
a president and trump was that our other
leaders going to deal with this guy,
you know,
is,
are they going to be frightened?
Will they make you know the nucleus just
in case.
No problem so far.
It turns out that if you're the
president of the United States and you
have good table manners when you,
when you talked to other leaders,
there's,
there's nothing that they would rather
do than deal with you because it's in
their best interest and it works.
So I listened to you on Sam Harris'
podcast and Sam obviously been here a
bunch of times.
I find him to be one of the brightest
and most thoughtful people that I know.
You guys obviously differ greatly on
the,
on the trump thing,
probably more than anything else,
but when you hear him make a couple of
those arguments,
whichever one you can pick anyone.
Um,
does any of it get to you?
Does any of it,
you know,
the moral center,
just what the,
what's really going on?
If things really escalated with North
Korea,
you can pick one out of the bag.
Well,
for those who didn't hear my
conversation with Sam on his podcast,
um,
I was not addressing the moral,
ethical dimension because I figured that
people are out on their own for that.
In other words,
my moral center is not much different
than everybody else's.
I have exactly the same preferences.
If you could do things without lying,
without insulting people,
of course I prefer that,
but nobody gave us that choice.
You know,
we,
we didn't get that candidate.
We had to lead the choices that we had.
So,
uh,
I think there was,
there's an illusion that Sam and I
disagreed on the ethical,
moral stuff.
Uh,
I simply take the position fair.
Yeah.
Right.
Because it really wasn't addressed
specific.
I wasn't,
wasn't directly asked,
I don't think I'm,
I take the position that if,
if a,
if a terrorist was holding your child
and the only way I could save them is
lying to the terrorist.
I will lie to the terrorist to save your
child.
Now,
if you wouldn't,
I'm not sure that you can claim the
moral high ground.
There are some situations such as
beating Isis,
you know,
having a good economy.
These are fantastically good things for
human beings.
If you had,
if the only way you could get there is
Ben's been some truths.
Um,
then I'm a little bit more flexible
about that,
but I don't think my moral look on this
as any different than anybody else's.
Yeah.
But what about just the concerns that
Sam and others,
like the people that are the real
critics.
Forget,
forget.
We can put them aside because if people
haven't listened to it,
it's not boring.
But when you hear people say,
well,
trump is so erratic and he's dealing
with erratic leader in North Korea and
all of the things,
you,
you basically think that that's all just
playing that,
that other higher bar this way,
and that in reality we're still doing
it.
Well,
we could talk about North Korea
separately because that's really kind
of,
there's nothing like that that's sort of
its own situation.
And at the moment I think he's handling
that.
Right.
Well,
let's talk about that.
Let's do it.
What do you think about North Korea?
So for,
for however many decades,
we haven't really had any pro progress
because we,
they promise things and then they don't
do them.
This is probably the first time that
little rocket man shall we call him,
um,
is literally worried that he will be
dead in the next 30 days.
I don't think they've ever had that
thought before.
And that's got to help in negotiations.
Now if you're thinking,
but that might make him,
you know,
fire off a nuke.
Well that's the only way you can be sure
your dad.
So right now he's only two choices are
dead for sure.
I don't think he wants to make that or
worrying about being dead unless he
comes to the negotiating table and there
seems to be some,
maybe a little bit of a hint of a
movement there.
Yeah.
So,
um,
but to your bigger question,
what about all the other stuff that,
that is problematic if you were to list
all the things that people consider that
the criticisms of trump on one column
and then all the things that people,
even his critics would say,
okay,
these things are going well.
You would find that the things that are
going well or generally real meaning
that there is less isis stocks are up.
Um,
you know,
we,
they did,
he did appoint justices that least his
side likes,
um,
immigration is down by 50 percent.
These are real and measurable things and
they matter and they're big.
If you look at the list of things that
people are criticizing,
it's well,
we think he might cause a problem.
We think this could go wrong.
We're concerned that people think about
him this way.
We think that his supporters are more
racist than they are.
Almost all of them would,
would be legitimately classified as
imaginary.
Now that's not to say that there
couldn't be bad things in the future,
but at the moment they are purely
imagined.
Yeah.
It's interesting because I was on Sam's
Ama podcasts and we discussed this and I
mentioned,
or he brought up the interview with you,
but that's what I said to basically.
I said,
look,
I didn't even vote for the guy I brought
on many of the week before the election.
I had hilary Rosen,
who's a progressive operative basically
to come on and talk about why not to
vote for him,
but then I had people like you and
others on and tried to talk to everybody
about it.
Um,
but I basically said that to say how
much is the things that he's actually
been able to do are basically mainstream
republican things that if any other
republican would have done the things
that he hasn't been able to do actually
show the strength of our system.
Because if you don't like the his
healthcare plan or the tax plan or
whatever else,
congress is fighting him and that's the
way the government's supposed to work
and the other things,
the tweets and all the other stuff.
It's like,
well,
that's just not.
That's just nothing.
It's just stuff you know no
to take healthcare.
So.
So if you were going to make a criticism
about the president's performance,
healthcare would be at the top of the
list of criticisms and this illustrates
what I call the the two movies on one
screen.
We're all looking at the same set of
facts and we're producing completely
different movies in our minds about
what's happening.
So some people will say,
well,
he hasn't solved healthcare.
That's a failure,
but my observation is what was the
deadline for that?
Is there a time you're supposed to be
done and that that,
that past.
Because I don't see the deadline.
What I see as somebody who left the
Republicans go first,
fail hard because they were going to.
They didn't have a plan.
That was gonna be popular,
scare the left while letting the right
fail as hard as they can,
and then once he do,
he says,
well,
maybe I'll talk to the Democrats until
he gets both of them in this situation,
setting the table,
he calls it.
He actually has a word for this.
This is not accidental.
You know,
if your brand is negotiating and you do
things that any objective person who
understands
the negotiating recognizes as correct
technique.
He's softening up both sides and it's
going to take awhile.
It might take obamacare to fail a little
harder.
It might take the public to see their,
their costs going up in obamacare.
That's not a good thing,
but it might be the only way you can get
these two sides that are on such
opposites somewhere in the middle.
Yeah,
so as he failed,
I would say it's a process and that's
probably the only way it could go.
How much are you concerned at all that
the people around him.
This is one of the things I hear about
that the people around in bed for either
certain things aren't staffed right now.
I ain't here,
I don't have that much of a problem with
that because I think the government
should be a lot smaller as a general
rule,
but,
but putting that aside,
that people say that,
well,
the intellectual acumen around him isn't
that great.
Like you've got these players around
him,
these people that understand a lot of
things you're talking about,
but not sort of like a serious group of
like intellects around him.
In what department does he really need
help in the State Department because the
international stuff looks like it's
going pretty well.
Does he need help in the economics?
Seems like it's going really well.
Does he need more help than general
Maddis to be an isis?
Madison is doing great now.
If you get down to the Department of
Agriculture and the EPA and stuff,
those are real arguments you can have
about whether you've got the right
horsepower there and I would,
I would listen to those arguments for
sure.
But um,
in terms of how much is staffed and
whether there's enough staff,
I'm still waiting for that to matter.
Well,
it sort of goes to that other point of
just the other things.
There's some literal things that have
happened and some maybes and could
issues.
Do you ever feel like you're stuck sort
of acting as his counsel publicly or
something?
I suddenly felt like I was like really
grilling you on trump and it was in an
odd way because we're obviously going to
talk about your book too,
but it's all intertwined.
You know,
it's funny in my mind it's always about
persuasion and about a more effective
way to see the world that does a better
job.
But predicting,
you know,
I guess is now year and a half ago,
um,
I said that he would do more than change
politics and boy is he changed politics.
But I said he would rip a hole in our
reality to let us look through and see
something completely different.
And he's done that because didn't you
used to think that facts mattered and
didn't use?
You think that if somebody said as many
things as he said,
that the fact checkers said,
oh no,
that doesn't,
that doesn't work.
That you couldn't possibly become
president and if you did,
you couldn't possibly have a good
economy.
You beat Isis and all the other things
he's doing.
None of it was true.
And if you were a trained persuader,
you could see that early.
You could see that none of that would
matter because you could see that his,
his persuasive skill was as strong.
Now I have to jump into just say one
point.
Yeah.
Facts do matter to outcomes and all
things being equal.
We would love to get the accurate.
But usually
when he's a nonfactual he's persuading
in the direction that we would like.
So if he says the number of deaths by
gun in Chicago or a thousand per day,
but it's really 10 per day,
we still need to fix that problem.
And he made us focus on it.
The fact that it wasn't accurate,
didn't matter.
It didn't.
Now,
uh,
and,
and I think he knows it and I think it's
conscious and he calls it hyperbole.
He has a name for it.
Yeah.
Well that was gonna be my follow up
question.
Do you think he's really conscious of
all of this stuff?
I would feel.
I guess I would feel better if I really
thought he was conscious of all.
If I knew he was conscious of it,
I guess I would feel better.
He's kind yet at the same time.
That would mean he intentionally.
These are lies.
I mean if,
if he knows them and he's and he's
intentionally doing it,
even if it's for all the reasons that
you lay out here in the book that still
advantage,
then it's an outright lie as opposed to
just an exaggeration or hyperbole.
Well,
I would say that.
Do you have to consider intention?
Uh,
at this point I don't see any scenario
in which the good of the country and how
he does personally are separated.
He has to do a good job for the country.
So if he's telling a lie that's good for
him and bad for the country,
that's just a fricken lie.
Nobody's in favor of that.
But if he says,
Hey,
you know,
we've got to fight extra hard to fix
this problem that everybody wants fixed.
And there's a little bit of an
exaggeration in that.
Well,
it's still the direction that we do want
to go.
It's,
it's so,
you know,
those situations,
you can call it a lie,
you can call it someone who didn't pass
the fact checking.
He would call it hyperbole because he's,
he's,
uh,
it's a sort of an exaggerated truth,
if you will.
In other words,
directionally it's true.
Just the details are wrong.
So as a guy that wrote one of the most
popular,
has written one of those popular comic
strips of all time,
the whole purpose,
I mean,
I think of,
of comic strips and stand up and
everything that you're getting to a
kernel of truth at the end of that
thing,
right?
Like every time you,
I assume,
is that,
is that fair to say that every time you
ever rode a strip that there's a kernel
of truth at the end,
right?
If you do it right,
if you do it right,
right.
So how can you also be the guy that's
saying that it's okay to live in a facts
still matter place like facts and truth?
There's a rope there,
right?
I love the US side question because this
is just a perfect way to make the point.
The comic strip is an exaggerated world.
It's,
it's just a crazy,
you know,
something that wouldn't actually happen
in the real world.
But what people say about it is that has
just like my job.
So they're looking at something that's
this crazy world and they're still
seeing the truth.
And so if you're a good cartoonist,
you,
you've made both of those things happen
that shouldn't be together,
you know?
Um,
and so that's a perfect example that I
get to see every day where people say,
that's just like my office.
And I say,
no,
there were no aliens in your office.
Somebody had exploded.
That didn't
happen in your office.
So stuff in the comics,
people regard as feeling real when they
clearly are not.
That's interesting.
Are you familiar with the term K Fab?
The,
uh,
it's the term that wrestlers use that,
you know,
that's the fakery that everyone knows.
It's fake.
We all know it's fake were.
And yet,
you're,
you're eliciting real emotions from
people that go there and pay you to do
something fake and have a real emotion.
And I think there is some connection
with that and what you're talking about.
And that trump was kind of,
you know,
he was a fan of wrestling.
He's,
there's those clips of him,
I think at Wrestlemania and taken out
Vince Mcmahon and the rest of it.
So he is playing that game.
He has merged theater and politics like
nobody's ever done.
And he just happens to be good at the
theater stuff.
And so he effectively merge them.
Um,
I don't think we'll ever see this again.
This is a very special situation and
the,
as I've probably said this before,
but um,
he has a talent stack of,
of individual talents that he's a,
b plus a minus that.
But there's so many of them and they
work so well together.
All of his persuasion stuff is.
His theater stuff is public speaking is,
you know,
his intelligence,
they're all,
they're all high,
but you'd say to yourself,
wow,
we've had smarter presidents.
We've had better orators orators or
eight people who speak better than I do
either one way or another.
We definitely have those.
Yeah,
but very few people have had that
combination with business experience
with,
with his ability to take criticism.
Even though people say he's thin
skinned,
you don't get into this game unless you
know you can handle the criticism.
Do you think trump derangement syndrome
is a real mental disorder?
I'm starting to actually.
I mean I'm being slightly facetious
here,
but I'm actually starting to Israel that
it's a real psychological condition.
Yeah.
Because I get into these conversations
all the time with fans and friends and
family and whatever it is,
and I just try.
I try my hardest to take the most
rational,
decent emotion and what actually has
happened,
how you may not like Gorsuch,
but that was just a mainstream can you
know that any mainstream republican
would have put this guy in.
Now you may be a Democrat and that's
upsetting to you,
but it's not.
It's not Hitler.
Hitler.
And so I've really tried to like take
some of the fangs out of these
arguments,
but I do find the level that people are
obsessed with this stuff.
No.
In all seriousness,
this is a legitimate,
fairly major mental health issue.
And you hear psychologists are actually
dealing with people who are coming in
and crying and thinking that the world
has exploded and there's a.
there's actually a good reason for it.
So if you look at the result,
it was a surprise to half of the
country.
So the people who were trump supporters,
even if they weren't sure he was going
to win,
what they got was a world that made
sense to them.
They thought all along he should win.
And then when he did,
even though
it was surprising in the polls,
their world was intact.
Everything that they thought about the
world seemed to be about right.
They just thought other people were
wrong.
But if you are on the side that knew he
couldn't win,
there's no way you were living in the
country that this monster could possibly
become our leader.
And then you woke up and he was you.
That's a classic setup for cognitive
dissonance is where you have to rewrite
the script in your head to make sense of
this new information and here's what
people don't do because we're all human,
so let me make this not a comment about
just half of the country.
So universal comment.
We rarely rewrite the script in their
head to say,
you know,
the best way to explain this is that I
was a fucking idiot.
Nobody does that,
and there's nothing wrong with that.
That's normal.
We don't do it.
You don't do it.
Nobody does that.
So they have to come up with a new
script that explains their situation and
so I think they've come up with,
my God,
there are more racist in the country
than we knew.
They voted this guy in a and he must
have,
he must have had help from Russia
because there's no way this happens in a
natural way because my world wouldn't
make sense if he could get elected just
by having policies people like couldn't
happen.
So in that situation,
these people are.
I hate to use triggered,
but it's a specific use of cognitive
dissonance there.
World doesn't make sense and they're
trying to make sense of it and it is an
emotionally painful experience,
which I have genuine sympathy for.
Yeah.
So as a guy that deals in persuasion for
people that are watching this,
that are dealing with.
Because I get emails everyday from
people,
I can't,
my brother won't talk to me,
my cousin or my wife won't talk to me.
I've gotten emails from people that are
doing divorces over politics.
What techniques would you tell someone
to do if their spouse was suffering from
this condition?
Well,
let,
let me,
let me tell you.
I was scrolling.
This is,
um,
I had postulated over the summer before
the election that when a Clinton's
persuasion game went from very weak to
nonexistent,
to suddenly just weapons grade when she
started calling everything that trump
did dark.
That's the work of a real expert.
And I have some speculation about who
that was.
But for our purposes today,
just say it was super good persuasion
that was not like anything she'd done
before.
And that captured the thought that he's,
he's a monster.
He's are racist as enough of every.
Everything you wanted to put it in that,
that one were captured,
had Clinton won,
the bomb would have been diffused
because her side would have said,
oh yeah,
we got what we wanted.
We avoided the monster.
The trump people would've said,
oh darn,
we lost.
It wouldn't have thrown them for so much
of the loop,
but it wouldn't have thrown the loop
where they sort of would have been used
to losing.
So it would've,
it would've been inconsistent with the
polls.
They wouldn't like it,
but they wouldn't be thrown into
cognitive dissonance,
hesitant,
right.
It would have seemed like a normal
world.
Um,
but this,
this thought that there was this,
this monster under the bed.
People lived with that as a real thing
for months.
And then when it didn't go away,
they have to continue living with it.
So that,
that was a setup.
So to answer your question,
how do you get out of it?
Like how do you cure it?
I had predicted a way back before
inauguration day that we would see the
following cycle or story arc,
if you will,
that on inauguration day it would be
Hitler,
Hitler marches in the street,
and we saw that and I said that after
several months of him not doing Hitler
things,
people would say,
all right,
well it's not as bad as we thought.
He's not a healer,
but he's incompetent and in and there's
chaos and he's just not going to do
things right.
And maybe that's just as dangerous.
So that was the summer.
Remember I,
this was all forecast by me way ahead of
time because you could see that this
would have to happen.
Right?
And then I've predicted that by the end
of the year and we're getting close.
People would start to say,
well,
he did get a lot of things done,
so maybe he's effective,
but we don't like what he's done.
Maybe it's not the justices they wanted
and the policies they wanted,
but that,
that part's just politics,
right?
We can all deal with that part,
but well will.
The only way you're going to get rid of
the,
the illusion that he's a monster is by
him doing non monster stuff long enough
that you just can't hold the illusion
anymore.
And I think that the,
what's coming,
and this is the fun part and this is
really the basis for the prediction,
is that every year at the end of the
year of the news organizations,
they sort of run out of real news and
they do the year end roundups and
they're going to have to say what did he
do?
And that list is going to be really
long.
And it's gonna be all this stuff you
cared about minus self care.
I think.
I'm not even sure taxes will happen.
Both the economy so strong.
I'm not even sure it's important
anymore.
Right.
Will probably get four percent with or
without a tax change.
Maybe they'll be something with business
taxes.
Um,
but uh,
at this point,
I think the list of things that he's
done that Republicans wanted is going to
be so long.
It would just be hard for people to hold
their heads that he wasn't effective.
And by next year,
if we get something with healthcare,
maybe something with taxes,
it's going to look like a hard to hold
the the illusion anymore.
Do you think the media fits in all of
this now?
Because I think that you can very easily
chalk up there and attitude and obvious
cheering at first for Bernie,
but then ultimately for Hillary,
you can chalk that up to why so many of
the trump people,
and I include myself in this,
that I'm thrilled the way the media is
crumbling.
I think it's phenomenal.
I just this this past week there was
this idiotic thing with trump in Japan.
You saw this with the prime minister of
Japan and CNN tweets the video out and
said,
you know,
implying that he's being disrespectful
by the fish
food in the,
in the Koi pond or whatever.
What they don't show you is literally
the second before that.
That's exactly what the Japanese Prime
Minister David,
right?
How do they keep doing this?
I mean,
I cannot chalk this up to complete
idiocy and ineptitude anymore.
How do they keep.
How have they not fired?
I mean CNN every day.
Should be just firing people,
throw.
They should be throwing them off the
roof of the Time Warner Center.
Well,
unfortunately the economics of the news
business has changed.
It used to be you could have the three
big networks and they can just deal with
the facts as they knew him,
but now I don't think you could make
money that way because people are
looking to feel to,
to digest the news that they like.
It makes them feel good,
so you're always going to have a media
on the right media on the left and I
don't think that middle may never be
filled because there's no way to make
money in the middle because if you go in
the middle,
both sides will say,
well half the time you're just making
stuff up.
Because interestingly I think the
middle,
whatever that middle is,
I think it does sort of exist in this
space.
The space that you're.
Even though you're not a creator on
Youtube or whatever,
it kind of exists in this land of of
Rogan and de Franco and me and whoever.
Whatever that influence is.
I think it sort of exists at the risk of
complimenting you own show.
You might be the closest thing and the
only thing I can think of that's in the
middle right now,
like easily identifiable as,
as a legitimate attempt to be in the
middle,
you know,
other people have their spin on things.
Right.
But I don't even see others trial one
compliment per year on the show of me.
So that was it.
That's it.
I was waiting for someone to do it.
We're already in November.
Yeah.
So,
um,
yeah.
And look,
you had to go outside the TV model to
even make this work,
but okay.
So you are thrilled with the way the
media is being destroyed,
right?
I mean,
is there any piece of you that misses
that?
We get our news from three places and
can make some factual sense together and
any of that.
I know,
you know,
I don't find any joy in that because
it's just something that's broken.
I can't get happy about that.
So I'm not happy about anybody's
destruction,
but I understand your point that it
feels like it feels like if people are
not doing their job,
you want bad things to happen to him,
but I can't quite get in that mindset.
I don't mean specific.
I don't want him to be hurt or anything
like that of course.
But just the general,
the state of this nonsense.
That's why when people say to me about
what trump lies about this all the time,
well Hillary lied about this all the
time.
Obama lied,
but if you like your doctor,
you can keep them.
And the,
the Syrian red line,
it's just like,
well all of them lie in.
They used to,
they just all aligned the same way.
They lied in a politician's way.
He lies in a new way.
I don't particularly like either one of
them but.
But there's a little bit of real politic
here and I think that's where you sort
of operate and just sort of there's,
there's reality and then there's
politics and they have a little bit
overlay.
Sometimes it's the only way I could
stake out a position that wasn't one of
the crazy on the right are
crazy on the left is by the persuasion
filter.
It was sort of a step back from politics
per se,
and that gave me a little bit of ability
to be as objective as I can.
Nobody is completely objective.
Um,
but I,
I just don't think that middle will be
where you make all the money.
The.
I mean you're,
you're,
you're kind of alone here.
Yeah.
Well,
I'm not making dilbert money.
I shouldn't be working on a comic strip.
That would be your major advice.
Right.
I tell everybody who started comics
started kind of extreme.
That's quit your job,
quit your job right now.
Yeah.
Do you think it's kind of funny that you
end up talking about politics so
directly because obviously before we
mentioned it,
I mean you were always sort of giving
people a grain of truth more about their
life and sort of the working world and
all of that,
but it was more social commentary,
but,
but this is a lot of politics now.
You know,
his way closer than you think because
since,
since the things I talk about are the,
I would say the illusions that we have,
you know,
in the comic I would write about the
illusion that there's,
this three hour meeting was better than
the two hour meeting.
That's just,
that was just an illusion.
Yet people buy into it.
It's a widespread practice and I just
took that,
uh,
you know,
that same mindset,
which is you understand that this isn't
real,
these things you're doing in the office,
these things don't help.
These don't make sense.
This new business policy just sounds
good on paper,
completely doesn't work.
It's really just the same analysis.
I just took it to a different field.
Yeah.
I'm curious,
has there been some kind of cost,
uh,
professionally or personally for you on
the.
Oh yeah,
I forgot to quote you.
I pretty sure you said that you do have
fuck you money.
I think that's what you said to me last
time.
So you may not care,
but I'm curious what the cost has been.
Um,
so I think I've lost 75 percent of my
friends.
Um,
I mean,
do you mean that literally,
I mean that literally,
I mean,
I don't know if you were just staking
out a trump position and then you going
to scale it back the 20 percent.
I mean,
I haven't actually done the calculation
but,
but it feels like that,
but really,
yeah,
I would say that's true.
I look at my facebook feed and it's
just,
I just,
I literally thought facebook wasn't
working for awhile and that's not even,
it's not working.
I thought,
oh,
it must be some kind of major problem
with facebook.
I'm not,
I'm not seeing anything from all of my
friends here.
Um,
and then financially a big part of an
author's income is speaking.
Yeah.
And uh,
I can say this now that now that I have
no speaking engagements lined up,
uh,
anytime in the future and if not for the
past year,
but I was making anywhere from 50 to
$100,000
just to talk for an hour that went to
zero,
meaning I have nothing booked in the
past year and nothing booked for the
future year.
And that's never happened anytime in my
professional career after the first five
years when Dilbert became well known.
Yeah.
I find that particularly bizarre because
a,
you're not a hateful person or any of
the things that people might say about
you or be the things that you're talking
about generally have come true.
So the worth of having you speak there,
they're still worth and having you
speak.
But I get it.
It's like,
well,
we're not going to pay a trump
supporter.
So yeah,
that's,
that's all it is.
And really even the people who were
making the decisions,
you know,
they understand the nuance and you know,
if you tell them,
well that's not,
it's not about the policies,
they get that,
but their job is to make sure that
there's a big room full of people who
don't feel bad.
Yeah.
So they're not going to take a chance
that the people in the room will have a
different interpretation.
Right.
That's interesting.
Was it mostly like corporate type gigs?
I thing it was almost entirely corporate
and big organizations.
Yeah.
So that,
that also shows you another symptom of
what's happening in the world right now,
right.
That someone who basically is just a
moderate,
decent guy who's saying some things and
maybe his is a supporter of a guy that's
not popular in the popular sense of the
word,
you know,
a corporation just doesn't want to put
there.
But online.
Yeah.
And,
but let me,
let me state that,
uh,
as you said,
I'm not going to be poor like that.
That isn't going to happen.
Um,
and I knew what I was getting into.
So,
you know,
you and I were,
we're professionals.
And so people watching might say,
oh,
that poor guy,
he walked into the buzzsaw.
We see the buzzsaw,
we choose to walk into it because
there's a,
there's a bigger something there.
And this case,
this was this weird special case where
people's entire worldview was going to
change.
I knew that when I saw trump enter
because he had that kind of effect.
And I,
I thought it would be helpful to be sort
of a guide to help people understand
what they were seeing so that they could
reinterpret the reality and to,
to something that was more functional
and less trump derangement syndrome.
Yeah.
Well,
as I said before,
I mean,
that's why you're good at what you do
because I listened and that's why I
wasn't crazy.
And that's why I think my audience,
I have no idea which,
if I was appalling,
my entire audience,
which way they voted or whatever it is.
But I think that for most of them they
were,
they didn't go off the deep end.
You know what I mean?
Like they actually didn't go crazy and
they've sort of.
I try to keep my people dealing in
reality,
which somehow is very special these
days.
I didn't realize it was special but.
But apparently it is.
Yeah.
Um,
I don't know how long it will take for
the people who are screaming at this guy
to,
to effect some change.
But I think,
I think the keys could be,
and I'm not predicting that these will
happen,
but these would be the keys if president
trump did something useful in North
Korea that really looked to people like,
oh my God,
I wasn't seeing.
I didn't see that common and something
good happened with healthcare.
Which by the way,
I think both of them are entirely
possible.
You know,
I'm not,
I'm not sure what the odds are,
but they seem very possible to me it
would be hard a year from now,
two to feel the same way about his
presidency.
Assuming he doesn't do any,
anything that's extra bad between now
and then.
Is that also just the nature of basic
human psychology that you can only
scream for so much time?
Like they've.
They've really dragged this screaming
out.
Right?
But you can't do that forever.
Your brain.
Well,
my mother had a saying and I don't know
where it came from.
She.
She said you can get used to anything if
you do it long enough,
including hanging hang long enough,
you just get used to it.
And I've predicted for a long time that
as,
as provocative as president trump is,
as long as he stays provocative in the
same way,
you will get used to it.
And I think you're starting to see that.
But there's certainly a big segment of
the population that is now close to
getting used to it.
Yet,
what do you make of the Russia thing?
You know,
I hate to say on camera.
Well,
there's nothing there and there's
nothing.
There never will be anything there.
But at the moment,
at this conversation,
there's nothing that looks like it's a
crime that,
that influenced,
that's involving the president directly.
Um,
I'd be surprised if there is,
but,
you know,
certainly if there is,
it would be some kind of technical thing
that he,
that the average person says,
well,
I didn't even know that was a grime.
So that's what happens when you get the
special.
The special prosecutor in there is
there.
They're looking for crimes now and at a
certain level of,
um,
you know,
money,
power,
influence,
people are doing stuff that's going to
violate some law,
uh,
or,
or an ethical violation.
So if you look,
you're going to find stuff,
um,
my guess is there's more smoke than,
than fire and that the smoke has been
sort of generated by the coverage of it.
Yeah.
Well,
every time they keep pushing more smoke
out there,
the smoke actually starts looking like
it also has a lot to do with Hillary and
the DNC.
So it's like,
you all better be very careful what you
ask for here because this could take
down all of you.
Well,
and then the question I ask is Russia is
sort of a weird relationship with the
United States,
you know,
there's sort of Frenemies,
we want them on our side but they seem
to be doing stuff to,
to bother us.
Um,
but we have fairly deep connections and,
and have had for a long time.
So there are lots of people having lots
of conversations at powerful levels
probably all the time.
Um,
but when you look at them and you look
at them through a certain filter,
you say,
well now it looks wrong.
Whereas maybe in a different time we
would just say,
well,
yeah,
why wouldn't we be talking to someone
who has so many interests that overlap
with ours?
Yeah.
That does show,
that show the
way things flipped very easily.
Now it seems like the Democrats.
I mean,
look,
if you took this thing to it's,
let's pretend there was,
you know,
some legit reason for them to be talking
about Russia.
Well,
what are we really saying then?
Are we going to depose the president of
the United States?
And you can't then put pence in because
he probably knew about it.
So you can't have his guy in there.
And then what are you really saying?
Should we go down the line of succession
should um,
you know,
uh,
Paul Ryan then be installed.
And
really what are you saying that,
because then if they actually hacked our
election and put the president in
office,
that's obviously an active war.
So are you saying we should do Gresha?
I mean,
that's why it seems to me we've got,
you know,
Obama running around the whole country
do and his $500,
thousand dollars speeches,
which I don't begrudge him,
but with that shit eating grin and
everybody else is out there doing their
thing where if they knew that the
president was a Russian spy or colluded,
it's like they'd be out in the streets
screaming about it,
but one of the things that really
strikes me is that there are things that
are alleged as a trader is illegal
activities that if you had asked me is
this traitorous or illegal,
I would have said it doesn't sound like
it to me.
For example,
if the Russians had some dirt on Hillary
and if they offered it to the campaign,
if you had asked me without any of this
news coverage in which we've all learned
more about how this works,
is it illegal to gather information from
someone who has information?
I would say,
how is it illegal to talk to people?
Why wouldn't it be illegal to know more
if it's true,
why would it be illegal to have true
information?
Now,
that's an interesting distinction
though.
Let's pause there for a second.
So if the Russian government,
let's say had been falsifying
information and passed it on to the
trump campaign and then the trump
campaign used it,
you would see that you would view that
differently.
So the information itself has to be
true?
Well,
yes.
I think people would view that
differently because that would look more
like a.
well,
either way it looks like Russia is
trying to influence things,
but just because they're trying to
influence things,
does that mean that the person who would
benefit from the information is is
forbidden from having it now?
This is where you have to be a lawyer to
know whether or not that's illegal.
I look at it and go,
okay,
I can get the argument that it might be
unethical,
like and get the argument that we
shouldn't do it.
I can get the argument that Russia
shouldn't be meddling and we need to.
We need to respond in some way,
but how is it illegal for a person to
hear information and way in what world
does the source of the information
matter?
If it's actual inflammation,
well that's why it's funny you saw when,
when,
what was it about a month and a half ago
when trump jr,
the whole week was that trump jr met
with the person who may have gotten some
information from the Russians or
whatever it was and everyone was
screaming about,
you know,
you get opposition research but not from
other countries,
blah,
blah blah.
And then just in the last couple of
weeks it came out that for sure the DNC
was at least working at some level with
either this Ukrainian guy or the
Russians to make the dossier.
I mean,
just,
it's like we don't even have to go into
all of it because it's just like you're
all dirty,
your own narrative and,
and it's,
it's such a confusing area that the
public doesn't have any idea what's
going on.
Now with Russia,
we know there's something about Russia,
something about lawyers,
you know.
And if you were to ask the average
person,
um,
you've probably seen these straight
interviews where somebody goes out and
says,
name the vice president of the United
States and they're like a mickey mouse.
You know,
they have no idea.
Right?
Imagine going out in the street and just
grabbing a person and say,
can you sort out the Russia thing for
me?
Can,
can you tell me who did what?
They're going to tell you that there
something about a Russian lawyer of
uranium on a hotel bad.
It's going to be this,
this mess of stuff that they've
conflated in their minds.
The public has no idea what's going on.
Yeah.
How do you figure out what news you
believe and what you think is true and
what you can actually trust?
Oh,
I think every situation you got to look
at it differently.
Uh,
so the first,
the first sort,
if I see it on either Fox or I see it on
CNN,
the first thing I do is go to the other
one because you have two tvs next to
each other.
Well,
I got a clicker and I wait because it's
not going to be at the same time
necessarily,
but I wait because my experience is that
on a factual basis,
they all pretty much get the facts
right.
It's,
it's the interpretation.
It's the priority.
It's how much attention they put it
switched pundits come on and say,
what about it?
That,
that is where all the,
uh,
the bias happens.
So the first thing is that they both say
it and if they do,
I start feeling comfortable that maybe
there's some truth to it.
Uh,
but then all the spin comes and almost
all of that is,
you know,
nonfactual spin.
So I,
I of discount all of that from both
sides.
Yeah.
Do you think anyone's doing the
persuasion game correctly on the other
side?
So whoever might be your intellectual
opponent buys into all of the things,
say of the modern Democratic Party.
Is there anyone that's kind of doing it
right?
Um,
even if you disagree with all of the
conclusions are what they're trying to
build.
And let me say something that I know
makes a,
you can make at least half of your
listeners just flip out.
George Clooney has game right now.
I don't think he can run because the
whole Hollywood Weinstein connection.
But in a recent interview I saw,
I saw so much technique that,
um,
I didn't know he had that much
technique.
And he basically was setting himself up
that if people begged,
he would,
he would run a.
now,
I don't know if you agree,
because once they did some polling,
they might find out he has some issues,
but he has the charisma and he has the
persuasion game that if he could bring a
little bit of substance,
he would actually be quite formidable.
I don't think he can be trump,
but he could probably really take a run
at someone else,
you know,
a regular Republican.
Uh,
likewise.
Mark Cuban,
he's definitely making some noise in
this space.
Right?
Right.
Now he did an interesting thing by
saying that he could potentially be
either a republican or a Democrat,
which was kind of clever because it
allows both,
both groups to see him until he commits
as well.
Maybe one of mine,
you know.
Um,
but I think somebody said that he said
he would maybe run as Republican,
but the Republicans have a long memory
and there's no way.
There's no way he gets elected as a
Republican.
But could he be elected as a Democrat if
you brought in some ideas that involve
technology,
for example,
that would maybe get us to better
healthcare or a way to get to free
college because that's the part that
Bernie was missing.
He had everything right,
except the connecting tissues.
Like how do you get there that you could
afford it.
Technology could probably get there or
at least you could make a story that it
could get there.
And I think it would be believable
because we.
Because I think because I think we can.
I think Hubert could,
could make that story.
I think he's got the charisma.
He's got the brains.
You might be able to pull it off,
but I don't know if he'll run as
Democrats.
So,
so not that I have any love of sort of
career politicians or people that have
just been around positive about.
But it's interesting.
You just went basically to all
celebrities.
Even Cuban in effect really is a
celebrity at this point.
Well,
I wouldn't charisma
if there had been any standard
politician with charisma,
I would probably gravitate to them.
Van Van Jones is very good,
he would be high on my list of
charismatic democratic,
um,
he agreed to do the show and then CNN
wouldn't let them do it.
So really,
so I don't know why,
I don't know where that puts my feelings
about him or at least he said he would
do it on twitter and then they said no.
So maybe he was just playing me for,
to sort of the public credit of.
Yeah,
I'll do it and then leave it to my guys
who will just say no,
I don't know the details,
but I find him credible,
credible story with the safe.
Um,
my guess is that he told you the truth.
Yeah.
Um,
so if we can't have sort of regular
politicians anymore because that's real
easy,
whether they're celebrities or just
because you're saying these people don't
exist in the world.
It seems that the longterm health of the
system,
it doesn't strike me as that great.
In that case that we're just going to
keep you living in a world where facts
don't matter.
We're going to keep sort of putting
persuasion sort of ahead of.
We've always been that way
world.
It's not a new world,
it's just that we,
we have a character in the president
right now who takes it to a level where
you can't miss it.
I think before you had the luxury of
saying,
well,
my site is telling the truth,
but we don't even have that luxury
anymore.
Like even if you're a pro trump,
you know that the fact checkers are not
wrong every time you just don't think it
matters because he's persuading and a
direction that you like,
like,
all right,
well to put a nice bow than on this
whole conversation since you've done a
nice job.
I think persuading people in general,
but I,
I am upfront and admit you've helped
persuade me in certain ways.
Uh,
I want some at you.
Adam's,
where's this all going?
Does this guy run again?
In a way?
It will be about three years now.
Uh,
does he step aside and the Democrats
finally wake up to some of this stuff?
Lay it out.
Give me something here.
I think you're going to see you
something good with healthcare maybe by
the summer.
I think that the economy will stay
strong unless there's some surprise that
we haven't seen,
but straight line it looks like it's
going to stay strong.
I think we'll hit four percent GDP.
I think that,
uh,
at the end of trump's four years,
unless something new happens,
it's going to look really successful and
if he's smart,
he will at least consider going out on
top,
especially because age becomes a little
bit more of an issue at that point.
And for a brand or somebody who would
like to go out and say,
okay,
you know,
I also have a company with my name on
it.
It might make sense to go out on top,
but he's also a really competitive guy
and so he might just want to take it to
the next level,
but I'm not sure that I'm rooting for
that because I think age has to matter
in that job.
Yeah.
And I suspect that even if everything
you predict there is true and
everything's going great and it looks
like he could win again,
I do think,
you know,
this is the guy who made the apprentice
and that it would be like he would just
anoint his successor and then that
person would have to do the job,
whether it's don junior or whoever else
it is,
but that he would then step off as the
king and you know,
not even risk,
you already pulled off one major coup,
so to speak,
and not even risk the second one.
Yeah.
It's going to be attempting to,
to keep the brand,
you know,
clean if he has a great four years and
just go out with that.
Yeah.
All right,
well it's always a pleasure talking to
you.
I feel that we should do this,
you know,
probably a little more than maybe once a
year or so.
And that way I can keep grading your
predictions.
Is Anyone tracking you?
Is there a blog devoted to Adam said
this,
he got this one wrong,
got this one.
I think everyone should be.
They should drop.
What they're doing is just track my
predictions.
I have them in my book win bigly.
Uh,
so you can,
you can see them there.
Yeah,
we'll put the Amazon link right down
below and yeah,
it's a pleasure as always.
Thank you so much.
And for more on Scott Adams,
you can follow him on twitter where he
does a lot of morning periscopes with
you.
Do you always have the coffee before you
start?
I could never talk to people without the
first sip.
I always have coffee before I talked to
humans.
That's a good,
good strategy.
That is a true persuasive technique that
you all should be taken into account and
it is Scott.
Adam says on the twitter.